meistens haben sie gar kein ich habe das
auto dann nicht berührt ist es einfach
so zusammengebrochen hallo mein name ist
luca und herzlich willkommen zu einem
spiel
ich habe keine ahnung was das ist dieses
spiel heißt airways myhammer und ich
oben
da ich das gerade ok zusammengefasst bin
ich gerade einfach mit meinem körper
dagegen gelaufen und habe überhaupt
keine ahnung was ich damit
es sieht kaputt aus ich habe dieses
spiel bei game gold gesehen und da hat
mir nur gesagt so hemmer ist das was man
da machen kann ist weiß ich nicht ich
versuche mal irgendwie hier in die tür
wie komme ich da das in sachen aus dem
mittelmeerraum aus charts ich habe kann
ich jetzt irgendwie ii
wenn ich die rechte maustaste gedrückt
hatte sich und dann
habe ich vollkommen daneben geschlagen
ich hasse dieses auto ich bin youtube
etwa nur porsche wahrnimmt dass du blöde
kuh
ich haue damit geladen einem hammer
gegen und nicht was ihr dabei wenn ich
damit einfach gegen laufe zerstöre ich
quasi das komplette auto das ist mal
wieder ein typisches lukas spiel kriege
ich davon mal kurz ins loma von dem
tollen schlag alles klappt kann ich
wenigstens das glas da oben hui
das war schon ein bisschen besser aussah
wir jetzt den hammer haben können wir
auch mal rein theoretisch jetzt hier in
das gebäude rein gehen um zu sehen was
sich darin verbirgt vielleicht könnt ihr
euch noch an den start vom video
erinnern wo es ja eine ganz normale tür
gab jetzt sieht das ganze allerdings so
aus ich war und ist noch ein stück übrig
geblieben
ich habe es mal wieder komplett zerstört
ich kann nicht wirklich den boden auch
kaputt machen
juli verboten du wirst jetzt erst mal
was passiert wenn ich
spawn wieder doppelt da oben ist noch
ein auto kann sein dass sich gerade auf
einer neuen map in das sieht irgendwie
alles kratzt ein bisschen anders aus
jetzt bin ich hier bei einer map
statuen waren ich weiß nicht was dieses
spiel für einen sinn habe das müsst ihr
mich auch gar nicht in den kommentaren
fragen ist kommen wir auf diese
kommentare luca was haben die spieler
eigentlich bin sind die du spielst
meistens haben sie gar kein ich habe das
auto ja nicht berührt ist es einfach so
zusammengebrochen die gegenstände haben
schon so viel respekt vor mir dass sie
einfach so zusammenbrechen ohne
irgendeine einwirkung von mir
ich stehe im auto drin gerade fängt das
spiel auch überhaupt nicht anzulegen
wenn ich hier versuche alles kaputt zu
machen das läuft schon glück alles noch
unglaublich jetzt nach zwei stunden habe
ich mal versucht hier unten wirklich
alle möglichen statik in säulen whatever
auseinanderzunehmen und das ganze haus
steht immer noch
wie kann das sein ich mache mir wirklich
gerade alle säulen irgendwie kaputt
sodass die quasi nichts mehr stehen kann
das ganze haus fällt aber nicht in sich
zusammen
das kann ja irgendwie nicht sein ich
sehe schon kommen dass ich hier gleich
quasi alles zerstört habe einfach und
das ganze haus schwebt quasi in der luft
oder kommt etwas runter ich andere
youtuber fahnen lamborghini oder c 63
amg oder ein boxer gts ich fand das hier
das ist dass luca mobil und wenn man das
luca mobil ein bisschen bearbeitet
bin ich tot
what the [ __ ] hier unten sieht
tatsächlich alles gerade leicht
verwüstet aus ich weiß nicht woran das
liegen könnte das war ich auch nicht
okay ich habe es hingekriegt das hier
gerade nichts mehr funktioniert es sagt
alles
wir haben das spiel tatsächlich gecrasht
das spiel hieß myhammer wenn ihr da
irgendwie den sinnen raus entschlüsseln
könnt dann schreibt mir das ja gerne in
die kommentare aber ich glaube da gibt
es keinen sinn in dem sinne würde ich
sagen das ganze spiel gecrasht
wenn es euch gefallen hat lassen
bewährte oder wenn es euch nicht
gefallen hat dann lasst trotzdem der
bewertung damals also eine positive weil
das heißt das ist das muss das kann das
soll das übrigens gibt es die artikel
den hier gibt es im luca shop wieder und
den rudi gibt's im luca shop wieder und
es gibt auch wieder dieses miley oliver
t shirt da das heißt wenn ihr denkt ich
brauche noch klamotten dann geht einfach
auf und damit sage ich jetzt auch